ja es gibt ja wenige momente in denen
ich mich alt fühle aber ich muss jetzt
mal gestehen es gibt einen moment da
fühle ich mich immer alt dann nämlich
wenn ich merke dass keiner mehr von
naturschutz und umweltschutz spricht
sondern auch alle von klimaschutz ich
erkenne an das ist ein großes problem
ist eine wichtige herausforderung wir
dürfen nicht die augen verschließen ja
aber klimaschutz gibt gibt nicht
kampflos für sämtliche eingriffe
beispielsweise in den straßenverkehr wie
wir sie diese woche in hamburg und
berlin erleben mussten an 34 tagen
mehrere stunden auf der a 100 auf
darunter 10 und anderen autobahnen war
der straßenverkehr lahmgelegt warum
klima aktivisten haben erklärt was sie
immer sagen wir haben keine zeit mehr
wir sind verzweifelt wir sind die letzte
generation und deshalb legen wir die
ziert den verkehr lahm ja so nennen sich
diese aktivisten wir sind die letzte
generation das finde ich anmaßend und
unklug apokalyptischen panisch und auch
etwas paranoid es geht immer weiter wir
müssen kreativ umgehen mit der
herausforderung die wir haben auch mit
der klimakrise selbstverständlich aber
das gibt doch kein recht dass wir wie in
früheren zeiten wie eine endzeit sekte
davon ausgeht dass morgen die welt
untergeht anderen menschen unseren
pessimismus aufzwingen nein das geht
doch nicht und man tut auch für die
sache keinen guten dienst weil wer von
diesen menschen die damals vielleicht
100 mehrere stunden im stau gestanden
haben vielleicht wichtige termine
verpasst haben beim notar bei der
hochzeit im krankenhaus ein
bewerbungsgespräch wird denn sagen ich
habe gerne im stau gestalten weil ich
dadurch das klima gerettet habe nein das
wird niemand tut deshalb würde ich sagen
liebe aktivisten sei es nun von ende
gelände oder von letzte generation kommt
zurück auf den pfad der vernunft redet
seit aber keine gefahr für den
straßenverkehr und bittet rüstet etwas
moralisch ab heraus aus dem
apokalyptischen schützengräben
das war ein leidenschaftliches plädoyer
da gebe ich direkt mal weiter harry was
sagen sie dazu also ich hab anderen
gefesselt fabelhaft also inhaltlich ganz
bei ihnen ich würde die burschen
versuchen von der straße schnell weg zur
allgemeinen wieder zu aber meine frage
wäre das der freiheitsberaubung der
kissler das ist doch letztendlich ist es
doch kein legales mittel seiner meinung
gehör zu verschaffen das ist richtig
deswegen werden auch immer die
personalien aufgenommen und wir haben
dann gelesen von 30 60 leute wurde die
personalien aufgenommen da wurden alle
wieder freigelassen einige haben sie
nach gleich wieder hingesetzt das heißt
das schöne wort not kennt kein gebot
wird so gewendet dass man sich nicht an
die regeln des straßenverkehrs und auch
an die bewegungsfreiheit halten muss und
leiter das spielt eben hin zu haben
oftmals solche radikalen klimaaktivisten
den vorteil dass sie von der
öffentlichkeit permanentem
schulterklopfen ausgestattet sind und
deshalb schwindet die kritikfähigkeit
aber wir sind ein rechtsstaat da haben
wir uns noch ein nicht und wenn jemand
sich auf die straße sitzt den verkehr
blockiert menschen davon abhält zur
frühschicht zu kommen und ich glaube es
sind sogar rettungssanitäter ist hat
widersprochen für einer seite aber habe
ich auch aufgehalten dann ist es doch
ein fall für den kadi und da müssen wir
gar nicht reden weil wir demonstrieren
geht darf demonstrieren gehen und wer
sich auf die straße sitzt der raub den
anderen die zeit und das darf es nicht
geben und berlin ist ein sonderfall das
weiß jeder der sich mit berlin bisher
beschäftigen aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das in münchen mehr als
einmal passieren würde ich glaube da
wird ganz schnell in berlin wollte
niemand zur arbeit aber es gibt einige
von diesen klima aktivisten die sich
wirklich festkleben lassen das ist
wirklich dann haben wir schon an
eingängen von banken zum beispiel macht
das wirklich stunden gedauert hat bis
man diese menschen mit diesem schweren
schweren hat ein klebstoff von dem
objekt der begierde also eine tür
beispielsweise los bekommen hat oder
dabei musste sie losschneiden weil sich
angekettet hatten und da finde ich
einfach da fehlt einfach in der
öffentlichkeit auch die kritik dass man
sagt damit desavouiert ihr euer anliegen
und das ist genau die grenze die wir
nicht mehr bereit sind aber akzeptieren
aber sie sagen doch genau dass das doch
fabelhaft und ich sage dir auch zu das
ist heute sich wir müssen gar nicht groß
diskutieren einer meinung ist es nicht
erlaubt das ist keine form es ist
wahnsinnig rücksichtslos gegenüber
vielen menschen die sowieso schon im
stau stehen es kann überhaupt nicht sein
außerdem ist es irgendwie nervt es auch
dass leute die in der früh zur arbeit
müssen
anstehen die gebirge da hocken und
trocknen welche klima apostel und wollen
die nicht durchlassen bei allem respekt
vor der frage des klimaschutzes ist das
ein schritt zu weit es ist einfach nicht
vorgesehen bei uns man muss ja einige
polizei hat ja auch einige demonstranten
festgenommen das je blick zu tragen
genau die gegen
lebensmittelverschwendung jahr hatte man
genau jetzt haben naja das grundanliegen
ich muss sagen ich bin ja hier ich bin
jetzt wahrscheinlich die miesmacher in
der runde vor allem aktuell mit blick
auf die krone pandemie und wie immer
protestierende da eigentlich das recht
genommen werden soll ich bin total dafür
dass man demonstrieren kann ich finde
das auch nervig ich würde es auch so
aufregen aber ich bin so stark ich finde
im moment muss fasst das rechte
demonstration mehr geschützt so können
demonstration wenn ich lange autobahn
setzte finde es ist keine demonstration
sind eingriffe die ja stimmt es kann
reden erfährt und leben gefährden wenn
jemand aus versehen durch fährt also ich
finde es schon sehr riskant und ist im
gegensatz zu anderen das ist anderen
demonstrationen die an der grenze des
legalen sind jenseits dessen wird es
hier viel zu wenig freue mich dass ich
mir da zustimmen da aber es wird viel zu
wenig kritisch diskutiert weil man immer
sagt ja ist aber doch ein wichtiges
ergebnis muss man aber ich behaupte es
tut wie gesagt diesem anliegen nicht gut
es wird überhaupt nichts für den
klimaschutz getan wenn ich zu spät zur
arbeit komme und es wird auch kein was
man im training erleben auch eine genau
und es wird auch kein so hoher
moralischer druck aufgebaut man will ja
dadurch herrn scholz und ein haar
wegbewegen noch schneller aus den
fossilen energie auszusteigen das wird
man nicht der zweck heiligt auch möglich
nicht die mittel das ist leider ein
alter satz den man in diesem fall
zustimmen muss und man hat allerdings
den eindruck wenn man das richtige ziel
schreibt dann ist auch über seine mittel
schreibt dann ist dieses mittel heute
legitimiert oftmals ich meine es gibt ja
verschiedene auflagen die man einhalten
muss die hier ganz offensichtlich nie
eingehalten wurden aber die auflage
maske und abstand das ist also das große
heiligtum auf demonstration wenn
menschen draußen an der frischen luft
während omikron ehrlich gesagt sowieso
auch einfach mal durch läuft weil die
maßnahmen nicht weg aber wenn
demonstranten draußen die maske nicht
tragen wenn die demonstration auch
pauschal auf präventiv untersagt die
große politische empörung über diese
demonstration habe ich jetzt nicht
gesehen und ich muss sagen ich bin da
auch bei dir eigentlich gar nicht
menschen wirklich gerade jetzt dass sie
demonstrieren wo sie wollen auf der
anderen seite denke ich mir mein gott
man kann auch einfach in jeder
innenstadt demonstrieren auf jedem
opernplatz oder sonst wo man muss nicht
auf die autobahn ich habe in der asb
gespalten ich bin da eigentlich ähnlich
wird und vielleicht extrem zwiegespalten
grenze ist eben offen zur
gewaltanwendung ich hatte neulich ein
streitgespräch im radio mit einem klima
aktivisten und er sagt wortwörtlich wenn
es kein klimaschutz gibt gibt es bald
auf die mütze und das ist natürlich dann
an eine sprache die enthemmt ist und da
müssen wir schon aufpassen also ob es
egal für klimaschutz oder für andere
anlegen wenn ich und auch verbal nur sei
dahingestellt zugestanden verbal nur mit
auf die mütze geben also mit
gewaltanwendung weil ich eben meine ich
habe das recht dazu weil über morgen die
welt untergeht dann über streite ich
genau diese grenzen des zivilen
vernünftigen erwachsenen des kurses an
dem ich ja teilnehmen möchte freunde wie
diesen der usa wies das
demonstrationsrecht dort oder gehen dort
die menschen auf die straße ein sehr
sensibles thema nach black lifes mara
also die menschenrechts proteste gegen
die rechtsverletzungen der schwarzen vor
allen dingen auch weil sich dort immer
wieder auch kriminelle darunter gemischt
haben und er die legitimen protestes und
geplündert haben und also auch in
mainhattan in der nähe von meinem
wohngebiet ladenlokale sind eingebrochen
sie haben vorher gelegt das war schon
ziemlich schockierend was da passiert
ist deswegen ich glaube dass so
exzessive also das recht auf protest ist
enorm wichtig da bin ich völlig bei
ihnen ich glaube dass wenn man gegen
recht und gesetz verstößt man sich das
den miss modem mitbürger wie sagt man
auf sich zieht und das ist dann
kontraproduktiv ist darf an amerika
demonstrieren unter corona bedingungen
man darf ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht so sicher ich glaube das kommt
dann auch auf den staat darauf wann ich
weiß nur dass donald trump eine seiner
ersten amtshandlungen war das recht zu
demonstrieren wollte er einschränken ob
wohl wissend wahrscheinlich was denn da
kommen würde also deswegen ich glaube
als grundrecht ist das ganz ganz wichtig
dass man auf die straße gehen darf
natürlich es geht unter wenn man einfach
nur so als graue masse daher kommt wenn
man die aufmerksamkeit durch kontroverse
aktionen auf sich ziehen kann und damit
hervorstechen kann und damit
medienberichterstattung bekommen kann
das hat es immer gegeben den 68ern es
wird es auch wahrscheinlich immer geben
das stimmt was macht eigentlich freilich
for future gerade habe ich mich gefragt
die sind hier nicht ganz so radikal aber
ich merke vielleicht ist das bin ich
einfach im absoluten corona tunnel
hierbei bild aber ich habe mir das
gefühl seit monaten nichts mehr von
facebook user gehört das machten die
irgendwie so etwas eingeschlafen vor
zwei wochen habe ich gelesen es geht
wieder los da war aber auch schlechtes
wetter und dann merkt man gleich dass
die teilnehmerzahlen erodieren dann kam
omikron dann kam omikron genau aber es
ist eben genau natürlich ist verfügt es
nicht ihn einzusetzen mit sowas aber
auch dort haben natürlich töne die also
der radikalität das wort reden auch frau
frau neubauer sagt wir brauchen einen
radikalen klimaschutz gut kann ich sagen
ist eine metapher nur in anderen
bereichen heißt es immer auf einen
ministerin radikal geht gar nicht also
ein radikaler klimaschutz ist dann
offenbar legitimen teilweise gewünscht
ein radikaler einsatz für was anderes
ist nicht so gewünscht also ich finde
bei radikalität muss man immer
vorsichtig sein erst mal sagen oh was
ist denn da gemeint und nicht sagen weil
es für den klimaschutz ist gibt so eine
art von guter radikalität ich würde auf
jeden fall sagen diese proteste auch
darüber zu reden sie zu bewerten ist
eine sehr gute übung weil ich merke ja
auch aus dem politischen lager dass mir
vielleicht mehr steht das und dass ich
irgendwie als liberal bezeichnen würde
dass sobald beispielsweise für
klimaschutz protestiert wird dadurch
gewisse befindlichkeiten sind dass man
das denen nicht so ganz gut und ich
glaube das ist eigentlich ganz gute
übung um aushalten klar auf die autobahn
setzen geht nicht aber ansonsten können
wir den menschen das demonstrieren
aushalten von meinungen oder auch von
protesten finde ich ein gutes jahr
zwischen volt in dem es ganz kurz ab in
eine mini und verbrechen sind dann auch
sofort wieder zurück